I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO SEE THE
MOMENT WHEN THE JUDGE ACTUALLY
READ THE SENTENCE, THE MAXIMUM
SENTENCE, THE ONE THE
PROSECUTORS ASKED FOR NINE YEARS
IN A PENAL COLONY.
>> Translator: FINAL VERDICT IS
NINE YEARS OF IMPRISONMENT OF
THE 9 MILLION RUBLES PENALTY IN
THE PENAL COLONY AND SHE WILL
SERVE HER TERM FROM THE DAY OF
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THIS VERDICT
AND TIME WHEN SHE WAS BEHIND
BARS FROM THE 18th OF FEBRUARY
2022 WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE
OVERALL TERM.
>> JILL, FORMER CNN MOSCOW BURRO
CHIEF IS BACK WITH US.
JUST WATCHING THAT IS, YOU KNOW,
IT'S HEART WRENCHING THINKING
ABOUT ALL OF THE FACTORS IN PLAY
HERE, NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH
SHE'S 31 YEARS OLD.
SHE IS SOMEBODY WHO IS QUITE
LITERALLY AT THE TOP OF HER GAME
IN THE WNBA AND NOW HE SHE IS,
ACCORDING TO THE TRANSLATION,
IMMEDIATELY GOING TO GO TO A
PENAL COLONY.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR A PRISON SWAP, BUT SINCE
SHE'S GOING RIGHT NOW, CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO OUR VIEWERS HERE
AROUND THE WORLD WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
WHAT DOES A RUSSIAN PENAL COLONY
LOOK LIKE AND ENTAIL?
>> DEPENDS ON WHICH ONE.
THERE WILL BE WORK TO BE DONE.
IT COULD BE HARSH LABOR OR
MAKING THINGS LIKE SEWING
UNIFORMS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE EXACTLY WHERE
SHE WILL BE GOING.
BUT THIS IS REALLY, REALLY
SOBERING.
BUT THIS IS KIND OF WHAT WAS
EXPECTED BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT
THE RUSSIAN LAW IS SET UP AND
THE FACT THAT VERY FEW PEOPLE
ARE EVER EXONERATED AND THE FACT
THAT THEY SAID THE GUILTY
VERDICT WAS WITH CRIMINAL
INTENT.
SO THE JUDGE IS REALLY PUSHING
MINOR LIKE SIX MONTHS OFF
BECAUSE OF THE FEW EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT THIS IS
REALLY, REALLY TOUGH AND NOW,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE TWO
POSSIBILITIES.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY'RE GOING TO
APPEAL THIS BUT IT'S REALLY NOW
UP TO VLADIMIR PUTIN BECAUSE THE
UNITED STATES HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT IT WANTS BRITTNEY
GRINER OUT AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS MADE THAT VERY CLEAR BY THE
ACTIONS THAT HE'S TAKEN IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
SO NOW, WHAT IS HAPPENING BEHIND
THE SCENES?
WILL THERE BE A DEAL?
I HAVE TO -- DANA, AS I'M
LOOKING AT THIS, I'M STRUCK BY
HOW REALLY DRAMATIC THIS IS
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, USUALLY WHEN
THINGS LIKE THIS HAPPEN, AND
THEY'RE NOT THAT COMMON BUT IF
THERE IS AN EXCHANGE, IT'S
USUALLY ALL ADPRGREED TO BEHINDE
SCENES AND SOMETIMES THE WORLD
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW SOMEONE IS
ARRESTED AND ESPECIALLY IN THE
SPY WORLD AND THEN THERE IS AN
EXCHANGE AND THEN IT HAPPENS AND
THE DRAMATIC MOMENT MIGHT BE TWO
PRISONERS WALKING ACROSS A
BRIDGE AS HAPPENED BACK IN THE
OLD SOVIET DAYS.
HERE, WE'RE WATCHING BRITTNEY
GRINER IN THAT CAGE IN A PRISON
GETTING THAT SENTENCE.
SO IT'S REALLY EXTRAORDINARY AND
DISTURBING BECAUSE YOU HAVE THAT
HUMAN DRAMA TAKING PLACE AND
THEN YOU HAVE THE BIG PICTURE
OF, YOU KNOW, THE RELATIONS
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND THE UNITED
STATES, WHICH RIGHT NOW ARE
ABISMAL AND THIS WAR GOING ON IN
UKRAINE.
IT'S QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
>> OF COURSE, JILL, ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
CONNECTED.
RIGHT?
ALL THOSE THINGS HAVE TO DO WITH
THE OTHER AND I'M GOING TO BRING
IN KYLIE ATWOOD.
JILL WAS TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THIS IS SO VISUAL, SO PUBLIC AND
THIS MAY BE THE WAY THEY DO
THINGS IN RUSSIA BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY BENEFICIAL POLITICALLY
IN THE MIND OF VLADIMIR PUTIN TO
SHOW THE WORLD THAT THEY HAVE
A -- AN AMERICAN SPORTS FIGURE
WHO HAS WON TWO GOLD MEDALS, WHO
IS A SEVEN-TIME ALL STAR PLAYING
FOR THE PHOENIX MERCURY BEHIND
BARS IN RUSSIA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT AND NOT ONLY
BEHIND BARS BUT BEING SENT TO
THIS PENAL COLONY NOW.
THAT IS HUGELY SIGNIFICANT HERE.
DANA, WE HAD BEEN DISCUSSING
THAT HER SENTENCING COULD BE UP
TO TEN YEARS IN PRISON.
THIS SENTENCE OF NINE YEARS IN
PRISON IS QUITE REMARKABLE, AND
I THINK WE OBVIOUSLY, WILL WAIT
TO HEAR FROM HER FAMILY AND HER
FRIENDS WHO HAVE BEEN PUSHING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO SECURE
HER RELEASE AND REST ASSURED
THAT THAT PUSHING AND THOSE
CALLS ARE ONLY GOING TO
INTENSIFY NOW THAT WE HAVE THIS
SENTENCE IN HAND.
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE SAYING THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO A POTENTIAL PRISONER
SWAP TO GET BRITTNEY GRINER AND
PAUL WHALEN ANOTHER AMERICAN
WRONGFULLY DETAINED IN THE
COUNTRY TO GET THEM RELEASED,
THAT THE BALL IS IN RUSSIA'S
COURT NOW.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY
ACKNOWLEDGING QUIETLY HERE THAT
IT IS RUSSIA WHO IS GOING TO
DETERMINE IF THEY'RE GOING TO
ACCEPT A DEAL THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PUT ON THE TABLE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS
PUBLICLY ASKED FOR THE RUSSIANS
TO ACCEPT THAT DEAL BUT THE
RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER CAME
BACK ESSENTIALLY AND SAID WE
WANT THOSE NEGOTIATIONS TO BE
QUIET.
TELLING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TO KEEP THOSE TO THE QUIET
CHANNELS BUT DANA, I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
JUST PUT OUT A STATEMENT AND I
THINK YOU GUYS ARE PROBABLY
GETTING THAT BUT I DO WANT TO
READ THAT TO YOU BECAUSE IT'S
SIGNIFICANT THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES HAS FELT A
NEED TO PUT OUT A STATEMENT IN
THE MOMENTS FOLLOWING THIS
NINE-YEAR SENTENCE FOR BRITTNEY
GRINER AND I'LL JUST READ THAT
TO YOU.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING TODAY
AMERICAN CITIZEN BRITTNEY GRINER
RECEIVED A PRISON SENTENCE THAT
IS ONE MORE REMINDER OF WHAT THE
WORLD ALREADY KNEW, RUSSIA IS
WRONGFULLY DETAINING BRITTNEY
GRINER AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND
I'LL CALL ON RUSSIA TO RELEASE
HER IMMEDIATELY SO SHE CAN BE
WITH HER WIFE, LOVED ONES,
FRIENDS AND TEAMMATES.
MY ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TIRELESSLY AND PURSUE
EVERY POSSIBLE AVENUE TO BRING
BRITTNEY AND PAUL WHALEN HOME AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE HOW THE
NEGOTIATIONS TO GET HER HOME
ULTIMATELY FOLLOW AFTER TODAY'S
SENTENCE.
>> KYLIE, STAND BY.
I WANT TO GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
ARLETTE SAENZ IS THERE NOW.
KAY
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM YOUR
SOURCES IN THE BUILDING BEHIND
YOU ABOUT WHY IT WAS SO
IMPORTANT FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO RELEASE
THAT STATEMENT MINUTES AFTER THE
SEN TENNTENCING WAS ANNOUNCED?
>> Reporter: IT'S CLEAR
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TRYING TO
ST
STAKE OUT HIS POSITION TO SHOW
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING WHATEVER
THEY CAN TO GET BRITTANY GRINDER
AND PAUL WHALEN BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE SEEN THE PRESIDENT
RELEASE THIS STATEMENT DETAILING
THAT THEY ARE WORKING TIRELESSLY
TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
RETURNED BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND THIS COMES JUST ALMOST A
MONTH AFTER THE PRESIDENT
DIRECTLY SPOKE WITH BRITTNEY
GRINER'S WIFE CHERELLE AS WELL
AS THE FAMILY OF PAUL WHALEN
TRYING TO OFFER THEM ASSURANCES
THAT THEY ARE WORKING TO GET
THEIR LOVED ONES HOME TO THE
UNITED STATES AND REMEMBER, AT
THE BEGINNING OF JULY, THE
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY RECEIVED A
LETTER DIRECTLY FROM BRITTNEY
GRINER WHERE SHE EXPRESSED FEAR
OVER HER DETAINMENT IN RUSSIA.
SHE HAD WRITTEN IN THE LETTER
DIRECTLY TO THE PRESIDENT QUOTE,
I'M TERRIFIED I MIGHT BE HERE
FOREVER.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVER THE
PAST FEW WEEKS IS TRYING TO SHOW
THEY'RE PLACING UTMOST PRIORITY
IN GETTING THESE AMERICANS HOME.
THAT'S WHY THEY OFFERED THIS
PROPOSAL TO RUSSIA FOR A
POSSIBLE PRISONER SWAP BUT NOW
THE FOCUS WILL BE ON WHAT THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS MIGHT LOOK LIKE.
OF COURSE, THEY HAVE SAID THAT
THAT COUNTER OFFER THAT RUSSIA
HAD PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED, THAT
THAT WAS SIMPLY NOT A SERIOUS
COUNTER OFFER AND NOW
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE WORKING
TO SEE WHAT NEXT STEPS THEY CAN
TRY TO TAKE TO TRY TO GET
BRITTNEY GRINER AS WELL AS PAUL
WHALEN HOME AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
SO WRONGFULLY DETAINED IN
RUSSIA.